and it's Wednesday afternoon here in
Europe and it's time for the Android
developers office hours I'm Sparky in
Munich Germany I'm joined by rich I met
in London UK Richmond I'm sorry
no Matt this week Matt so if you didn't
Amsterdam I think J something comes I
Drive a conference in in Holland Matt in
a really really convincing yeah from
England as well I am welcome to this
week's office hours as usual we won't be
talking about anything that's not
previous been announced but fortunately
finally we almost pronounced it two
weeks ago when this started reading my
pocket we didn't and now we are free to
talk about some of the awesome new and
much rather talk about developing and
writing apps than the new devices right
well I'm glad you said that Sparky
because there's some amazing new api's
as well in a Android 4.2 hopefully we'll
be able to touch on those over the next
hour as well welcome to all the people
who have joined us in the Hangout life
good to see some familiar faces there
and some new ones and jelly bean yes we
should get started does anyone in the
Hangout have any questions for us today
my one's kind of a big can of worms
house multi-user handled with respect to
external storage okay so first of all
out and graduations on changing your
lower third I see there now a member of
booyah the early Kickstarter Android
console gaming awesomeness that
hopefully we will all be using soon
multi-user turns straight into one of
the new features of Android 4.2 on the
Nexus 10 it comes with multi-user
support we do have multi using right
here at low I can switch between two of
my profiles regarding external storage
yeah a lot of people have been using it
just basically it's a temporary dump
area for large files and a lot of
applications I've seen through that what
happens if you've got the same
application that's running under two
different users are they is the
application going to see the same area
for those two users and the user will
see a different view of the data okay so
if you asked for get external storage or
they actually get return same different
cool cool so we've got user separation
any of that later the hard believe that
the hard-coded string slash SD card has
been grandfathered in as well so if you
were doing it wrong like please you know
don't do that but I think we've catered
for that as well but at the same time
each app will only be installed once on
the device so if you do install an
application and then another user goes
to install it it will just instantly be
installed so you don't have to duplicate
all the actual application and apps data
it's just the user specific data so
sharing being your own private area to
the point of view should be transparent
to you like you shouldn't have to write
any special code for handling multiple
users cool so when you've got two users
will each user see the applications the
other ones installed no you get to go
and install the application and if it is
already installed it'll just enable it
for you but you don't get to see what
the other person has installed now
cool thanks I appreciated that I
remember back in the day we had a sort
of a semi proprietary fork of Eclipse
that could only be installed per user on
Windows NT or Windows 32 NT X B whatever
and man installing Eclipse separately
for every user account that you wanted
it on ouch I'm glad we don't have to do
that okay anything else from inside the
Hangout and welcome to whoever just
joined us I had a people know everyone
catch the announcements this week about
Android 4.2 and then Nexus 4 Nexus 10
anyways right
anyone planning on picking one up yeah
just not generally nice points are very
very competitive I've got to say and the
resolution on the ten themes incredible
is it really noticeably crisper than
other ten age tablets tanks rendering to
me is beautiful my my favorite example
is I bring up a reader app like for
instance The Economist and I pull up the
exact same article on the Nexus 10 and
one of the older generation like a zoom
or a galaxy tab and just look at the
rendering of the article on those two
tablets side-by-side and you'll be
convinced yeah yeah I mean almost up to
print PTI's now if you look at row
monkey's latest post I think at the
moment he's got a photo of you know the
corner of the screen and you wouldn't
believe that it's gonna have not
superimposed image on top it's just
phenomenal it is yeah is that good okay
that's one say wait another quick
question do you know anything at the
full point I was running on the Nexus 7
it's a 3d version peace out and the 3d
version of the Nexus 7 was announced I
don't know if you guys have had a chance
to play with it but is it in the
territory where you get multi-user on it
or is it considered a non tablet device
and you don't get multi-user think it's
not running multi-user right now the
only device I know that's got multi-user
at the moment is the Nexus 10 I haven't
seen it on the Nexus 7 but it's a good
question I will try and resolve that for
you thanks in the chat window down the
side Patrick has announced on before
that Francisco what do you think about
the battery life of the Nexus 10 and the
Nexus 4 thanks take you though
separately
Nexus 10 has got an insanely long
standby life made it for three months on
standby
based on the drawer in this capacity
yes generally a very very good battery
life is very large batteries in them and
good power efficiency from the chips
we're seeing and the Nexus 4 we've both
been using as our main phones for a
while now and we're not at droidcon when
not at joy : a bigger Patras than all
the previous Nexus handset devices and
more efficient operating system has made
for me
a device that easily gets through a day
we'll just have to see whether you pick
yours up and silly things like the
inductive charging is amazing so I have
an inductive charger on my desk and on
my bedside table and so every time I sit
down I just put the phone down and it's
charging so it stays charged because
it's so easy I don't have to think about
plugging it in or unplugging it when I
get up I just put it down and pick it up
if the 10 have inductive charging as
well no phony before just the four so
mine is currently sat at 82% full after
6 hours and 14 minutes without without
any charge you can see that but it's
doing very well right now I mean your
breakers whether it gets to my date yeah
yeah I haven't had that problem with it
yeah I was concerned about switching to
a device that doesn't have a removable
battery but the trade-off being that it
has a bigger battery inside it and of
course it has inductive charging coil
somewhere in the back and I've been I
know charting like is it just as quick
Bobbsey won't be as quick but is it
still pretty speedy compared to a cable
I don't really know yeah I think so and
identity that pick down overnight it's
charged for now I would it do a full
battery charge I'm not sure I really
want someone out to bring a really nice
range of furniture with inductive
charging built into it coffee tables
with little inductive charging points in
the corners and things so you can just
don't have to have these wires around
nokia did a pillow for their lumia for
inductive charging and you kind of sit
there and think what would you do
carrying this phone round on a pillow it
looks like something from the royal
household yeah so yeah the other thing
is the games on the Nexus 10 look
amazing that's one of the
ei games Mass Effect infiltrator Need
for Speed Most Wanted just look insane
at 2500 and the scary thing is when you
use the HDMI out or wireless display it
has to scale down for a full HD TV scale
it down to 1080p so it's absolutely
flying as well very good frame rates on
here got a massive 30 inch monitors at
my desk it's got the same resolution as
that the a-15 chip yeah okay let's do
some development questions unless
there's one more yeah in the cyber
Patrick a question about screen sharing
in 4.2 when it requires some kind of
device in between so yeah it's based on
miracast is the the wireless screen
shows I guess what you're talking about
so if your TV supports miracast which
I'm not sure if there any other nail but
I hear it's emerging standard at which
people are going to adopt there not to
be no until then I believe there's a
range of dong balls either on the market
now or coming out which you can use to
kind of retrofit that miracast support
into your kind of existing TV so yeah
right now the answer is probably most
people have to buy some kind of dongle
and to do that but in the future
hopefully no additional devices required
yeah you mentioned standards like DLNA
but usually they just do media streaming
showing the videos and audio they won't
allow entire desktop sharing off of a
device whereas this is you can do
mirroring where you can send a separate
stream to the second screen now in
Android 4.2 with the second screen api's
you get notified when a second screen
plugged in or connected and you can send
a completely separate set of views to
that screen and the cool thing is that
an dnase base is pingbacks on an
existing network whereas miracast I
believe this built on top of Wi-Fi
direct so you can have a direct
connection between say your TV and your
device without having to have another
and Wi-Fi you know access point in
between which is kind of cool I see
Pavel has asked us an actual programming
question what is the density screen size
bucket for antenna we see more buckets
introduced in the near future correct me
if I'm wrong I believe it would be an
extra-large XH
dpi is alright great and as of API level
16 there exists a constant for xxhdpi
but yeah but we haven't really done a
lot with it so I had a post on Google+
yesterday which some people might see in
saying that yes the tablet is an X like
an xhdpi screen but launcher on our
tablet devices picks a launcher icon for
your app from one density bucket up so
that it can render it slightly larger
see how a larger icon in launcher and on
the home screen so for that reason yeah
you need to provide an X X HTTP I and
icon in order to get a really
beautifully crisp icon I got a kind of
development question it's one that you
might not be able to answers so do you
know when the 4.2 SDK is going to be
available generally historically it
tends to get shipped when we launch a
device or open source or reach the
factory image so historically that's
what has happened so when that happens I
guess but I don't have a date okay yes
Yossi xxhdpi 480 yeah that's nothing I
see X X is just a and I guess a redirect
for a number I think it gets even turned
into 480 dpi by a a PCT by a apt so you
can actually just use drawable - 480 dpi
rather than draw with us okay nothing
like being prepared for the future
yeah a couple of benefits like it's like
where's it going to end if you keep on
adding excess it's kind of silly but
then the other thing is also makes your
resources nice and ordered in Eclipse so
don't know what the DPI if the new HTC
device was being an ATP find the actual
I think was 440 okay sister not quite
480 but but that said I mean these these
these are all flex there's kind of
pick ranges so write it so it may very
well be there's something with an actual
density of 440 might sort into the 480
bucket anyway it might be an X X sure
mm-hmm
one of the other nice features of 4.2 is
when you're developing for multiple
screens you can put a virtual second
screen on your device and see what what
will render like inside your application
so in the developer settings there's now
a new setting which I'll bring up in the
developer options for ya it's one of the
api's I'm really excited about actually
having an actual API to draw st.
separately to a second screen so you can
you know have your game controls on your
phone and the game output up on your big
TV you can't really see it but you can
simulate a second screen here on slide
your screen the second screen that be
what appears on to the TV set or the the
other screen that you're connected to
yes you can against that without having
to have second screens so now how long
do we have to wait for Nexus DS I don't
get it Sparky your screen is that what
da stood for a note in the EM okay so
shall we hit the water rater and get on
with some other questions for this week
unless we go Feeny joiners any other
questions from people in the Hangout you
hear me now yeah first of all I wanted
to try something with the Google
Calendar maybe do something very very
simple but without using the without
showing an intent to the user and
basically schedule an appointment into
the calendar yeah is it I know it's
possible I saw some some code is it
considered a good convention or I must
show the user the exact appointment and
scheduling
depends very like if you have a screen
basically showing the same
nation that will go into the great
events Creek I think just that within
your UI and if you just basically be
creating what the candor UI shows
they're not probably say this is the
intent the basic idea was to just use
the calendar as a sort of time stamp for
actions you do like went to the market
10:15 answer the phone 10:20 and so on
so on just use it as a timestamp to all
events you want to record on your yeah
so you probably create your in kindness
you probably wouldn't like write those
into the users kind of like Google kind
or whatever you probably want to create
your own mu or whatever calendar and
then create events and that so then the
user can wholesale turn that calendar on
and off and you know I didn't show those
events I think it's probably sounds like
a good solution there's actually a great
article on rockin Android if you know
that blog by Wolfram yeah he's just been
doing a couple of pace lately about
working with the gander so I encourage
you to check those out and I oh Sh I
have an example right when you added
that it when you pinned in an item from
that friendship presidential calendar as
well yeah there's a sample code in the
Google okay I'll take your things just
one of what you guys thought of the
photo spheres that you've been seeing on
Google+ you see Hugo's video and how to
create a photo sphere from outside our
building 44 I saw yours
you've got tilt didn't you yeah I did a
couple more last night as well but I
haven't posted them yet I might do one
from this hangout so you can get to see
everything in the room it's good point
two-thirds photo okay
I'm just looking through the what's new
for Android 4.2 and of course so you
guys you guys know that the right way to
make photosphere is not to turn your
body around right if you if you if you
swivel your body around and move the
move the phone in a cylinder you're
going to get parallax effects that make
for bad stitching if you want it to
stitch properly you need to actually
pivot the camera around the focal point
of the lens then you're going to get
your own face in it
right I don't know one see I think it's
going to depend on how far away the
thing is that you are making the
photosphere off so the ones I've taken
from very large buildings and outside
don't seem to have that problem I guess
for the ones I've taken in the office
maybe have more of that from that I just
might be more careful taking it that's
exactly parallax is way worse on nearby
objects yes exactly
okay can we move to the motor rate today
excellently the I have not had as much
time to go through the moderator this
week as I usually do fortunately some of
the other readers have done it for me
yeah thanks Chris
just get some answers so thanks guys yes
I'm writing an app that listens to
incoming SMS and if the SMS contains
special text I want to prevent it from
being received by third-party apps eg
Hanson I try to work broadcast and
sitting under a priority it didn't work
how can I do this and Chris basically
said that these other applications all
set there are the receivers to maximum
priority which means they get it first
there so there's no way that you can
determine elastically jump in line in
front of them
in other words sorry but no no unless
you want everything unless you want yeah
the pumping moisture at the moderator is
a question from Mitch Nick butcher it's
not really a question yeah oh yeah I put
that in there because we had a problem
with the GDL event and we couldn't
update it with the links so I had it in
the moderator page and do the job
because without that I wouldn't be here
is there a way to alter the standard
font used say Roboto light across a
whole application including action parts
or do you have to do this manually each
activity in fragment this is by kirsten
he also says changing the font is fairly
difficult jellybean allows you to use
Roboto light condensed via the new
family XML attribute 3 jelly beans
increases technical is on this way I'd
like to create a custom text view and
override subtype phase to inject your
custom file then use that text view
instead of the standard one Nick what do
you think of that I don't know a better
way of doing it across the entire
application in one fell swoop you could
do it in jelly bean not not too bad you
could basically use the style create
custom style right where you over you
find out where the text where the fun if
a family is set and override it just
goes home through flight or yeah it's
using the font family thing but to
retrofit that onto a pre jellybean world
yeah it's not easy I know last week I
talked about sticking of always an
animate layout attributes in the style
at the top level would this work her
this not work for that so yeah it would
totally work in the post jellybean world
where you can set the font family
attribute for the entire thing but in
pre jellybean before the font family
attribute no but why would you ever want
to do that I think the reason that
connection bar and everything is good is
because it's familiar if you start
wholesale changing a ring is this your
question Chris no I'm Santa
I'm never Chris in London and then
answer by Chris in London what was a
conversation with yourself perhaps going
on what can I say I'm schematically
minded I'm an engineer not an artist and
I would never want to screw with the
stock UI
yeah I just want to be able to do what
it does I don't care what it looks like
yeah god this is setting off alarm bells
it's question question why you need to
do this is my advice
okay elgyn says I'm integrating a +1
button but I want to use a token
returned by a Google auth util dot get
token with one of the scopes Google API
is /aa / + not me but a first +1
interaction still shows an extra
authorization dialogue this is possible
I presume he means is it possible - who
what show it without getting on receives
the auto Kunia so they don't need to get
the second authorization dialogue I
would slope your shoulders that straight
off to the Google+ developer office
hours they manage their own API
libraries and things I haven't put a +1
button on the things that have
real-world URLs thank you can +1 the
whole definitely +1 the app listing in
the Play Store the Play Store URL but I
think it would be more beneficial if you
had a recipes app and you have + running
the recipes and the recipes on the web
you know who's the link because then
someone sees the +1 in Google+ and they
can click on it and there's some way to
go to + running your app with the place
where your app seems like a very good
thing to do to that yeah I can see that
being in your about screen or something
like that if you had some kind of a
little +1 of this is speculation of
course because we have unless you tried
it Google+ developer office hours from
developers.google.com slash light we've
got a couple new people on the hangout
welcome newcomers do you have anything
that you would like to bring out for
discussion
I recognize Leslie there in the purple
shirt hey there good see any questions
this week Leslie no no okay anyone else
okay next muffin is it any best
practices guidelines is are there best
practices or guidelines for using Roboto
light sensor of light a font family in
the app combining with other five
families
for instance using light font-family for
headers big texts and normal for
ordinary text so we will physically say
yeah we we don't have any official
guidelines yet it's something I'd like
to see us lead on a little bit better in
my personal opinion I like it for big
texts are like headers like you say that
I think it can work really well if you
provide some contrast and relief by
using robots of life and also for
secondary texts as well so if there's a
piece of information which isn't of
primary importance
rather than using a different font color
or the size per se you can use a
different way to give it relative
importance my caution there is using
light fonts at smaller sizes you might
end up affecting legibility especially
on smaller screens so be cautious with
using it too much so I'd say stick with
Roboto
normal weight for most of good body text
as it were and because that's a fun
that's been optimized for most of these
like general reading operations and it
works for a variety of intensities and
then use something like Roboto light or
fin yeah in less often in kind of like
places to give relief so use them used
to use the lighter weight typefaces in
the larger sizes where they won't get
anti-aliased away yeah yeah I know from
the pretty much the earliest days of
WYSIWYG typography the general guidance
has been used multiple you know multiple
appearances and your type sparingly you
don't think accent not not mishmash and
I don't know about you guys but yeah
there were definitely times early on
when I was like ooh this computer has 25
fonts I must use every one in my
document otherwise yeah I might be
missing an opportunity and I think the
opportunity I missed was legibility yeah
well one of the things I always think is
well that a screen can get too busy if
you have multiple font sizes so I've
seen screens where people are trying to
use the size of font to basically
determine the importance of the
information so you might have like a
headline in the list item and then some
secondary text and there might be
account in a third font size and so on
and that can get really busy if you're
basically having all these different
like you know line Heights essentially
doesn't really scan very easily it's
quite hard to process it makes you think
about it more and so what you can do
instead is even use color or even a lot
lighter font face so you maintain the
same cover line height or X height and
just have some slight contrast in the
weight of the font instead so it makes
it a bit easier to read I think a lot of
HTML renderers are kind of annoying in
the way they deal with h1 h2 h3 h4 etc
because they do they do a scale in size
and weight quite a lot and it kind of
makes for a little busy appearance okay
so before we move onto the next one
one other nice new developer API that's
come along with Android 4.2 is the
daydream we now have I guess a similar
concept to screen savers when the device
is plugged in or docked or charging the
device will kind of go to sleep and you
can choose what's going to be on the
screen at that time whether it's going
to be the weather forecasts or news but
of course your applications can make use
of these api's to show your own data as
well the user can choose to have your
own daydream showing up on the screen
right now I have one from currents I
love the photo stream and you can see
the not very well we definitely want to
get off the tree do need to put the HTML
on here yeah you can interact with the
currents as well as they're coming
across onto the screen and see all the
latest news it just sits there whilst
it's charging giving you the latest
updates information it's a similar API
two by four papers and you'll be seeing
that in the SDK when it comes out it's
called daydreams or daydreams is the
consumer feature whose just called dream
in the SDK so once the 4.2 SDK comes out
search for dream fact there's already in
the compatibility there's a basic dream
in there which you can probably take a
look at and have a look at some of the
api's it offers it's going to be similar
to something like the widget it's this
kind of like pervasive awareness so if
your application is you know updating
the background
offering up new content it's another way
to surface that it's kind of cool you
can see someone's like a big you know
football fan or something like that you
might have transferred news or something
whenever you put your phone down it's
charging it might just kind of bubble up
yeah I've I've switched between having
the weather online the weather forecasts
and the news it's quite nice just to see
things going past that you're interested
in very configurable as well what was
the name okay got a question and sidebar
he says still no longer a 3d camera in
the Nexus line and I want the 3d images
I just want to see the depth of vision
interesting which is credible say yeah
I've got a lovely LG G slate tablet did
I think it's got 3d on it then he came
for that right yes yep there was a it's
a proprietary yeah it's quite funny that
every OAM who produced a 3d device never
followed it up with the second device in
the same line the Optimus 3d was a
one-off this LG slate was a one-off the
there was an HTC phone as well that was
a one-off I got the feeling you didn't
work well though she did have the second
in the Optimus 3d phone range at
Barcelona this year just never really
saw a launch but at least it was thinner
he didn't have that big bulk on the back
for the two cameras still made my brain
hurt after still native right now if you
look at that screen and didn't just
freeze but yeah if you're really
passionate about that I guess the things
you could do would be petition LG to
contribute it to AOSP perhaps and beyond
that right
there's something i well what could you
use for that I mean maybe infer
something from focus that would be
interesting maybe just try to get the
focal distance out of the camera in DI
or something
yeah it's nothing moaning I'm interested
in like getting the device it's fairly
easy to get a device but I would like to
see this kind of sensor to be more
widespread
and that's why I asked about this
eventually be included in the future
Nexus devices because you know if it's
under 1% of the of the market share
towards the point of great big trading
application for such such type of use
case all right the oxygen sensor is
everywhere and yeah applications to mr.
Rubin yes yeah I mean the place where
you'd expect it to take off first would
be on the 3d TVs and consoles and things
like that is gonna they've had a lot of
chance for it to happen as yet it hasn't
really my best experience with that has
been Gran Turismo 5 on a Playstation
with a 3d TV that's pretty and other
people in the room jumped from we
crashed all over their 3d glasses on but
I think still needs another step change
in 3d technologies for oh is a screen
thing I thought it's a camera thing so
you can see yes you can really make the
create amazing concept like if you if
you type in SMS while you're running you
can get you can get warning like a red
background if you are doing an obstacle
so you save your face typing an SMS
while you're running really Google Voice
input filter for panting and speak to it
whilst you're running and it just takes
deep breathing I'd wait for the car the
Google now car to pop up that says
you're about to run into something in 30
seconds whether you're running really
slowly moment in Austin Powers just like
that thanks my thing where are we now
Sparky uh next question the moderator I
am trying to monitor the CPU usage of
running processes by running the command
80 billion adb shell top it works well
in general but when testing it out plays
music CPU usage for the process of
running a service is at 0% also on Stack
Overflow link included
I suppose it's probably because of its
being handed off the heard word you know
keep up a sample you hand it off to the
audio subsystem of the CP of a step back
yeah handling
sounds like you chops not representing
the GPU or any other accelerators the
other thing would be that as well as
handing off to the service if it's not a
rooted device adb shell top may not show
you all the processes running UNC
systems ah yeah
could be worth testing on a rigid device
to see if you do get any any extra
information that's relevant so the next
one could you please suggest a way to
create a video slash at a video of your
app slash game we've had this three or
four times in the past on the office
hours the recommendations are buy a
nexus 4 with wireless display and a just
take my phone and I pointed at the
screen and a hold still hold still so
the most recent videos I've made have
been using the hardware accelerated and
OpenGL accelerated emulators that seems
to work very well for me and then screen
capturing software on whatever system
you're using to create the video
otherwise you can use HDMI recorders and
a device with HDMI out that works very
well as well black magic has some great
boxes for that kind of thing
but the devices yeah using two devices
you taking a video of a screen as an
idea of course yeah your best results
are always gonna be HDMI capture second
best is probably going to be emulator
and then using screen capture oh it's
just those emulator all something like
BlueStacks perhaps even so you can run
it on your host machine that's an
interesting idea I hadn't even thought
of it mm-hmm yeah he suggests android
screencast i agree' android screen crust
there anything that's using ADB screen
capture and a little bit on the sluggish
side maybe one or two frames a second
probably stay clear of that how well
does it work
sorry the the BlueStacks how well does
that work because I haven't really tried
it
anybody anybody tried bluestacks Alma
student I've played around with an early
alpha version of it and it was a little
sluggish and a little slow they may have
improved it since then but could use and
row VM yep
as a junior mobile were talking about it
at droidcon last week straight and uh
Gen Y Mobile and Rho VM the answer
VirtualBox based yeah under IBM and
there was also a product from a company
called luma trade at droidcon which was
kind of a cradle for a camera that would
sit over the top of the phone so you
could lay the phone flat and then just
record straight from that camera and
that's about two hundred and fifty euros
I think finger in the way so the terms
what you want if your app if you want to
demonstrate people interacting and
that's one thing I quite like the credit
videos which use the show touches things
so if you do HDMI out capture turn on
show touch it touches from the developer
menu then you get a little like
translucent white dot where you're
touching which I think comes out quite
well in put a v8 see yossi has provided
the URL for every over um thanks for
that was he and question here will the
third-party app widgets be able to hook
into 4.2 s new lock screen functionality
or is it limited to system apps how many
are possible per lockscreen
assuming we will get this I don't think
we have a definitive answer on that one
right yet sorry Sparky Sparky was just
about to answer the question maybe he
had the answer before dropping out the
answer was for you to know pony to is
that the answer
you're gonna read something into that um
but yes there'll be a developer API
you'll be able to add a lock screen
widgets
similar to home screen widgets I haven't
seen the API myself yet so I can't
really comment any more than that moving
on okay okay I'm trying to set the
scroll position in a remove list view on
a NAT widget without any scrolling
animation
unfortunately the usual set search in
position is not removable any hints on
how to achieve this is it even possible
mr. widget even this the scroll to some
remoteness if you want an app widget no
I have not done that without any
scrolling animation unfortunately source
legislation is not very much about the
others you know I have to try that out
you could ask it on spec overflow sir is
that Chris I don't think you can because
the ListView runs and launcher and so
you can't access that at all
so no I can't think the way you can do
but you seem to be implying that you can
scroll it with a scrolling animation I
just wonder if you can realize the
widget at a different position yeah you
can but not without the scrolling
animation didn't try that the best thing
we did was imitate a scrolling list to
avoid the scrolling animation we did
divided the widget to three parts and
show every every time we show a
different part under anything new of the
action bar in 4.2 I don't think so I
haven't seen it in I have to wait for
the final SDK and check the diff again
but okay Sparky is going to join us as
soon as he can he's had some technical
issues with his battery running out does
Nexus 7 support miracast no it doesn't
even support HDMI out so I couldn't
support miracast the new version will
support but it needs NHL's a book it
most likely needs the HDCP case
installed has bridging which wouldn't be
on if it's not HDMI enabled so even if
it did it wouldn't be able to display
protected content which is
stop it playing google play movies and
stuff and it seems to be the device of
choice for doing that kind of thing so
true but mirroring the screen and
playing games on a TV using the device
and things like that wouldn't require
those necessarily I don't know I also
had a look at the miracast list of
approved devices and it's not up there
at the moment there's currently only the
Samsung's echo P TVs which are yet to be
released the Nexus 4 Optimus G and
Galaxy s3
mm-hmm so I would say no for now but if
a new one comes out because the new one
that's launched with 3G has a different
power controller in it so it could in
the future but I wouldn't see as
possible in the short term yeah further
comments on it than that where we have
to next page
my company is developing a Bluetooth
low-energy device will Android 4.2
support ble in the SDK
no thanks I haven't checked I think
that's way too four point two launchers
to see what finally made the cut more
didn't what could I do wrong I get a
legal state exception with opening the
options menu the exception comes from ad
view in the phone window open panel did
I somehow break the activity lifecycle
why yes it did something sounds like you
did the specified child already has a
parent you must call remove you on the
parent first sounds like are you
inflating a fragment or something you
facing is something that I think when
you're doing your inflation of something
you're doing it wrong or you trying to
do it more than once
it's very redone which is green
that's something that yeah we should
bounce that one into next week's office
hours that kind of question we need to
get a little bit more in advance so that
we can have a good look through the the
pages of stack traces and code that
you've attached to the report doesn't
make for good watch time to do it live
yeah to me my first gut instinct is that
you're probably inflating something
that's already attached to something
else one of the parameters when you call
inflator to inflate there's different
XML stuff is you give it a parent he say
whether or not to attach it and it
sounds like you're saying parsing a true
when it's already attached to something
we should leave that to error they
should just pass false hmm
so whenever you have many options
created name can will do advanced on
next week
thank you you just joined us in the
Hangout if you go hey there you go good
see have you got a question for us today
yeah actually I have
yeah please yeah I was at fee ik this
weekend we were hacking on our food F
and it has a few beautiful issues with
listbox with the checkboxes okay and I
had some problems there what making this
checkbox selected after the data is
loaded so I have a cursor loader which
has load some stuff for the database
yeah and then I won't wanted to make it
select it of course it was well it was
VX I was hacking and doing ugly stuff in
the in the adapter yeah but that didn't
work on all devices for obvious reasons
and then in the end I said up with just
loading the data to the cursor loader
and then after they did have of loaded
iterating the cursor again to set the
selected the check item on the on the
ListView yeah but it feels a little bit
clunky so I was wondering what well
what's the proper way to do it or is
this the proper way to do it because I
asked around to some other deaths and
they you know didn't really have had a
proper answer so see extending see
simple cursor adapter right yeah so
using your bind view method there so
that would be the right place to find to
whatever the case is data is to your UI
right the other thing I did that but
then it messed up well I think what
happened there is that the checkbox is
then maybe selected but the ListView
itself doesn't know if selected for some
reason Heatran synchronize the state of
the control within the list item with
the selected state of yeah yeah I guess
that's what I'm trying to do because
what makes sense is that because you
call set item check I guess that's what
is called from the list
mm-hm so that yeah reflects the state
and then the viewed also gets updated
which is quite nice and likewise if you
touch a list item then it's
automatically reflected in the list but
yeah I assume some problems there I'm
not sure what I would you generally make
sure that the list is in sync with your
adapter and those kinds of things for
selecting especially for things that are
checked yes sir if the data in the
adapter is changing yeah outside of the
list then you got to notify the list of
what's going on and if the user is
pressing the item on the list you've got
to notify the adapter but he's changed
the dataset behind it what's actually
depressing on the list automatically
worse it's not nothing that you have to
do for that but my problem was loading
the initial values from the cursor
adapter because yeah it's loaded and if
I would set it on the view yeah yeah
wouldn't it for some reason wouldn't
reflect I'm not sure because yeah what a
multi set mode setting on the list it
sounds like you've got multiple items
yeah I said that too well multi spirits
is he saying it's multiple yeah so yes
are you loading all the data into the
list once and then going around a second
time for all the checkboxes then well I
basically now did it on the what is it
the unload finished or what's the meta
thing in the cursor loader its aha so
what event what I eventually did and
what worked on all devices was just to
iterate the cursor again see what's
selected and then call this set item
check but obviously I don't think that's
the proper way to do it but I wasn't
sure now it might go Phillies you should
be doing this in Bungay yeah okay yeah
wait until you've got the data before
you yeah I'll just try it again to see
if I can figure out what is okay so hey
if the Nexus 4 made of soap that was my
seven again it's about this one day yes
so still a nexus 7 it's no no Dexter six
and a half now came in on the chat
window from Francisco I want to find the
nexus 4 but I don't know whether to buy
now or in a couple of months maybe
Google can buy now
oh yeah we're setting up now and then
yes he says you should override the bind
view method
I'd say by now like I got the eggie
eggwin and I haven't really been butting
up against the storage limit I don't
play tons of big games probably get 16
gig weak enough I would get a 16 gig are
you talking about the Nexus 7 XS fours
say I do have the 8 gig Nexus 7 and it's
only got about 6 gigs of user-accessible
storage and that it goes fast I mean I
think I've got probably four games each
of which has more than a gig and a half
of extra data so there you go there's
these stories yeah yeah totally I'm like
a 16 gig Nexus 7 and a ok gig Nexus 4 as
well actually and I haven't had any
issues with it but if I was buying one I
definitely go for the sixteen for myself
I used a lot of the Google services
surprisingly enough so a lot of my data
is in the cloud yeah my musics in Google
music and Spotify
not much local let's see 11 hour flight
to San Francisco to get a man to
Beaufort will be where you use it the
most yeah yeah yeah and then the Google
Play services have rolled out into more
countries or I'll rolling it into more
countries so you can buy movies and do
things like that aren't they yeah musics
coming
movie is coming movie purchases are
coming through we already have movie
rentals that's brilliant
awesome music Nerva yeah they're going
out on Monday as well and I got missed
in a slew of announcements but yeah
that's coming to UK Germany France yeah
yeah it's good
yeah it's gonna be amazing
I've just can't wait for that well I see
a lot of promotions that go on in Google
music on the US side and some of the
promotions are insane you get and I wish
I could buy them and I press it
especially if you guys like us kind of
moving between devices you know fairly
often then yeah you don't have to the
pain of like moving all your music over
or whatever it just follows you around
yeah I mean I've had the cloud bit yeah
walks on up very proxxon so nicely he
one top tip oh are you gonna say sorry
no you're gone I always have this
playlist called offline on my google
music and whenever I sign into a new
device that's the one I just pin is
offline and then if I'm on the web or on
any device and I move anything is the
offline playlist it instantly sing us
down to all my devices it's kind of cool
so if you buy a new track I just said
it's been placed offline because I go on
the the London Underground a lot I need
offline music so I can always play this
up which is fun okay al says he's just
read the blog post and Google Play Music
is heading to UK France Germany Italy
Spain this November do we have anything
left in the moderator I don't know what
happened while I was offline
I'm just looking now there's one about a
chronometer yeah I would like to use
Roboto light for
chronometer but it seems the width:0
enlight differs from the others at which
their digits hence there is some
shifting when chronometer passes zeros
is there any way to solve this problem
I've been using another phone I have the
same issue
I've been redoing a chronometer style
application recently and I get a wiggle
in the time when I'm using Roboto light
so yeah you can change the font you can
choose not to just have it centered you
know fix the position we go is a feature
drives me insane I'm not quite sure you
know that it's not fixed whip you can
ask Christian why it's not fix it or
should it be quick fix with its open
source you could edit the glyphs make it
fix it especially if it's just a zero I
didn't know which character it was that
was doing the shifting but uhm yeah I'm
not sure if it's basically fixed width
or not I did you see it's shifting can
you see that brown why no at what point
is it going to decide that this isn't
all just white sneak preview of the new
ultimate stop watching time they're
coming soon to the Play Store thank you
very much Marie well we're out of
questions from the moderator as far as I
know and Patrick says yeah but this
isn't the benefit of google play music
right now oh I wouldn't say that I would
say it drives users into the Play Store
where they'll also find your
applications as J increases traffic to
the more users with forms of payment on
record that's easier than to buy your
apps this is true but if you're asking
yeah direct integration api's things
like that there aren't any
there's no again there's no API so if
it's games or anything like that it's
certainly true that several times a week
I go to Google Play and I look at music
and it says it says get music for free
and I click I'm using for fetuses Google
Play is not available in your country or
Google Play Music as I say ok fine I'll
go download an app instead you need to
release the original soundtrack your
game yeah
there's a scheme where you can sign up
to sell the music that you made you
ain't yes totally much like you can
isn't that developed that there is a
similar thing for it yeah you can share
music with people for free you can find
it's good it gives just am inside Google
music for all of them any other
questions yeah you're right there are
benefits to develop I yes it's it's that
whole mall thing which I develop with
Google Play right we're trying to make
Google Play this place you go to to buy
valuable content and I think yeah it's
like a training thing for users so
people get used to going there and
spending money and having a trusted paid
relationship with the store and I think
that's a really good thing for
developers actually I haven't been
checking the comment thread so I'll just
have a quick look-see and I send in
questions on Google+ can you recommend a
Bluetooth keyboard for the Nexus 10
haven't tried any sorry I have tried a
Wacom tablet and that worked very nicely
with markers but I haven't tried if
anybody hasn't tried hasn't tried it and
you get the chance to try out the
gesture typing it's magical huh okay if
I only mean you or us for the next
couple weeks yeah yeah yeah even even on
the 10-inch tablet which is perfectly
big enough for touch typing the gestures
still work wonderfully I use my left the
fact you don't just which keyboard or
anything like that because like when I
have two hands I I found my tap out and
when I have one hand this way there's a
really meta question in the comments how
do I post new questions yeah no I think
he's asking about where this chat stream
is of course it's inside the Hangout so
people from outside can't see it we
always try and read those questions
there but you can ask questions in the
moderator at developers.google.com /live
forward slash Android right most more
specifically that you are all that rich
said and then find this event yeah at
the bar rater for this event yeah
Jamie was asking maybe he missed ehe
because he joined 14 minutes in about
the other cache directory for multiple
user accounts get external cache
directory if you do the right thing and
you're getting all the you're calling
the system calls to get the directories
then it should just work transparent
into you and they're now sharing right
no yeah we've individual paisa when does
for I went to come for the Galaxy Nexus
so basically only the external storage
is shared between you know the whole
world yeah we can't comment on these six
guys in exes because we don't know but
typically what's happened in the past is
it tends to be a couple of weeks like
older devices will tend to get an OTA in
a couple of weeks after device it the
new devices go on sale yeah yeah
basically let's let the dust settle
other new stuff because yeah so like 4.1
came out with the Nexus 7 right in
Google i/o and then was what a couple of
weeks about that before it Oh TA to the
Galaxy Nexus I mean that's been typical
but I don't think both of these devices
also have wired HDMI out of some sort or
another as well as the miracast
the Nexus 10 as a micro HDMI slot on the
side and the Nexus 4 is using in port
yeah swim variety of display port which
adapters appear to be appearing on
Amazon actually because the HDMI and NHL
adducts has always had to be powered
right you always have to plug in of how
source as well as mates you might
whereas that believe this slimport
doesn't require the power so it's just
an adapter it doesn't require the power
but it still has a passcode on so you
can still charge your phone was this
president probably a good idea but yeah
the one that I've seen so far so I'll be
picking one of those up for presentation
and another dongle to buy another to buy
a new TV to buy with miracast support
cuz they don't stick ok just blows my
mind to think of using a phone to drive
pictures out of my
42 inch TV yeah those TVs I read these
days right we are so living in the
future I'm so excited about this at the
to screen any feel I think it's going to
drive a whole bunch of interesting paths
I totally agree the to screen API
absolutely awesome for gaming for apps
presentation even YouTube
well even YouTube all these things can
benefit
so yeah the a can be released yep if you
want to start thinking about it
basically you'll see the second screen
is going to be a bit like a dialog so
your app completely contains it it's not
like you can have one thing going on one
screen and running an over activity
there entirely link to your app owners
like a dialog which is on the big screen
it's not thinking about that how you
might draw to another dialog as it were
and that will have its own context a or
load the right resolution drawables and
things for the screen size and whatever
of the TV it for any on if there are any
compatibility layer for Google TVs
second screen API second screen API is
just feel like passing intents and
saying go run this right hmm it doesn't
actually do a companion app type thing I
think it's a kind of a different problem
of similar name okay virtual Matt
Android we stefaned are then I thought
let's thank the guys at sony Sony
developers are giving me this t-shirt
droid phone as well Android attack thank
you very much Sony that terrifying
teacher it's kind of Halloween right
Halloween theme going all over the
office today so a big Android crashing
cities seem to work for me and with that
it's the end of this week's hangout
thank you all for joining we will see
you again next Wednesday 2:00 p.m. we're
slightly shifted out of the u.s. time
zone right now because they change their
clocks at a different time to us say
queso them in seven hours I guess right
catch them in seven hours and have a
good week and thanks guys thank you